I said late last week that I believe the
Democratic primary race is down to two
candidates those candidates are Bernard
Sanders and Joseph Biden the numbers
show you that we now have Joe Biden
polling 28.7 in an average of recent
polls Bernie right there polling twenty
four point three in an average of recent
polls far back in third place is
Elizabeth Warren at fifteen so I don't
really think anybody else has a shot at
the nomination here I don't think Budaj
edge has a shot at the nomination
I don't believe Andrew yang has a shot I
don't think Klobuchar has a shot I don't
think Tulsi has a shot I don't think
steyr has a shot and I don't really
think Michael Bloomberg has a shot
either but I actually can put together a
path to the nomination for Bloomberg
that I simply can't for the other people
that I listed so let's talk about
Michael Bloomberg a little bit here
um Bloomberg has accelerated to fourth
place okay he entered this race very
late he spent an insane ungodly amount
of money to buy his way into fourth
place averaging almost 8% now okay Pete
Budaj edge has been campaigning who the
hell knows how long at this point and
he's going nowhere he's just been stuck
and Michael Bloomberg has almost caught
up to Pete Budaj edge already and I see
a path for Michael Bloomberg now I want
to be clear I know there were people who
were furious they're gonna misunderstand
me I'm not supporting Michael Bloomberg
I'm not voting for Michael Bloomberg in
the primary I don't think that Michael
Bloomberg winning the primary is likely
but I've identified a path where I do
think Bloomberg's shot is being
underestimated by the polling that we
see and I think that he will end up
doing better than a lot of people
predict this is merely because he's
pouring money in like that's all this is
he's just buying his way in and he's
being strategic about where he pours
that money in the way that the polls are
going between Bernie and Biden Bernie
Sanders may well win a number of those
early primary states that will deflate
Joe Biden's campaign let's take a look
at some of the polling when we look at
Iowa now Bernie has taken the lead quite
this
basically when we look at New Hampshire
the second state to vote Bernie is also
ahead their Biden fight fight Biden is
fighting more for second place with Pete
than for first place then you will have
in Nevada either a split between Bernie
and Biden or one or the other will win a
little bit but it'll be close a little
get a similar similar number of
Delegates and then the fourth primary in
South Carolina will almost certainly go
to Biden
by a bigger margin Biden's been way
ahead in South Carolina for a while so
imagine that after the first four
primaries we have a graphic up on the
screen with the first four primaries the
number of Delegates in each state
remember as long as you get 15% you get
a share of the delegates based on
current polling so if Bernie wins if
Bernie wins the first three or the first
two and it's sort of a split in Nevada
and then Biden wins in any case if you
look at an average of recent polling you
could have some Bernie wins with a
bigger win by Biden in South Carolina
and you could end up with for example 39
delegates to Biden and 31 to Bernie or
something close to that
now after each primary Bloomberg will
concentrate his spending more and more
on the March 3rd Super Tuesday States
the idea of course getting to the 15
percent threshold in some key states
including California that looks tough
Bloomberg's only polling six in
California but there's a bunch of states
on Super Tuesday
and if Bloomberg based on how effective
it's been to spread his money around so
far if Bloomberg concentrates another
hundred million or who knows how much
two hundred million three hundred
million in those Super Tuesday states we
could get to Super Tuesday and Bloomberg
pulls a bunch of Delegates he could be
in actually a reasonable third-place
position if he keeps climbing in the
polls merely at the rate he's been
climbing so far if Biden and Bernie keep
trading off if Biden looks increasingly
tired and slow you could see a case made
by the establishment on March 4th that
Bloomberg seems as viable as Biden
Bloomberg has more momentum than Biden
and Bloomberg has way more cash than
Biden you could see the estab
get behind Michael Bloomberg and then
it's anybody's question what happens
next now all the caveats I'm not rooting
for this scenario I don't believe this
is the most likely scenario I don't
believe this is a good scenario for the
country this is just that I think
Michael Bloomberg is more viable than
those who say any day now yang will
start winning all the primaries or
people who say boo de jedge who has been
even for four months any day now he's
gonna come and take leads and win some
primaries or Tulsi any second you'll see
she'll win Iowa New Hampshire and then
it's off to the races
no Bloomberg has been steadily rising in
proportion to the amount of money that
he pours in if he concentrates the money
in Super Tuesday states he could come
out of Super Tuesday with some delegates
some momentum and possibly move the
establishment behind him and away from
Biden again meant to deny Bernie Sanders
the nomination let me know we think it's
a possible path not saying it's likely
it's possible it's more likely that
Bloomberg is the nominee then Budaj edge
or yang or Tulsi are the nominees let me
put it that way